hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
video I'm going to answer question from
one of my readers in Oro who is asking
about the videos that I make how I make
them and why I made them so specifically
wrote in asking hi Evan you are just a
great guy for being consistent with your
messages thank you I have two questions
for you one in what way do these
messages you send to people positively
impact your business I mean economically
or financially and to do you have people
working on them and sending them out for
you or do you have to write and work on
people's questions new ideas
continuously when do you have the core
of your business to take care of as well
I want to say something like this but I
need to know if it's worth my while
thanks andorra so a couple of ideas here
for you on on how i create these videos
most of the videos that i create come
from reader questions just like this
just like the one that you wrote in I
don't make money from these videos
sometimes they're sponsored by a
corporate partner but most of videos are
not sponsored I do the videos because I
really like helping out entrepreneurs
and this is what gets me excited I'll
usually create the videos once a week
and then send them out during during the
week once a day and it's the best for my
week you know answering reader questions
and be able to create these videos for
you guys I do almost everything myself
so I'm you know staring at my camera
that i set up myself what I usually do
is print off the questions that I have
for the week so if you see here I've got
you know my pages of questions and I'll
write notes under what I want to say but
usually they'll just be free styling you
know whatever comes into my mind as I'm
talking about in whatever question that
that's been asked the only part that i
outsource right now is the video editing
so i started doing all of that myself
and i found that you know I wasn't the
best video editor was okay at but time
to bring on
a little more professional and so I've
hired somebody Assad who is my video
editor and once i'm finished with these
recordings i put to my computer put them
in dropbox send them over sad and he
makes him look great with the intro and
the music and all that sent them back to
me and then I'll be the one posting it
on youtube and posted on my facebook
channel and Twitter and all that stuff
so I do most of the work myself and
right now you know the only revenue
model from it typically is when I get
some of the videos partnered with a
corporate sponsor but for the most part
I do it because I really like it you
know one of the best parts of my week
and I really enjoy helping entrepreneurs
when I first started my website I was
just sharing information there was no
business model behind it I was just
following something I was super excited
about really passionate about and
trusted that somewhere in the future the
dots would connect in terms of my
regular business I have a team working
with me and they run most of my business
for me so I'm lucky that you built it up
to a certain point where i'm not really
doing much on a day-to-day stuff so i
can spend more time doing this kind of
stuff which i really enjoy helping out
other entrepreneurs so i'm following the
same path of the videos right now there
isn't really a big business model behind
it but i'm trusting that somewhere in
the future the docs will connect because
I'm doing something I'm really excited
and passionate about and hopefully I've
been valued to to my client to the
entrepreneur community like you guys so
in terms of if this is something that
you should focus on or not I would
really say make sure you're super
excited and passionate about it that way
you'll put in the work to make sure
there's a good product nut you know
it'll start to take off if you're not
really excited about if you see it just
as a marketing opportunity then it may
not be something that you will end up
committing to you you'll probably quit
it the first giant hurdle that you face
so when I started these videos I did a
super low budget you know I had a tiny
flip camera that was under hundred bucks
and didn't have a tripod didn't have any
lights did it out of my home or against
a backdrop in my office and they were
they were pretty bad if you go back to
look at some of the videos you'll see
that that they were pretty bad and then
as I got a couple
them funded by a corporate partner I was
able to invest in a better camera and
lighting and I also learned a lot about
you know how to make these videos a
little bit better and so slowly so
slowly they get better as money's coming
in so one of my business principles is
not spending money to making money so
they want to spend a lot of money on a
project that i didn't know if i was
going to stick to or not and then as I
got a little bit of money coming in from
corporate partners I was able to invest
and make these videos better but again
most of them is just because I like
having fun with you guys I like
answering the questions and it's just
something i'm super passionate about and
hopefully that leads somewhere down the
road but can't predict it right now so
hopefully that answers your question if
you guys liked the video and you like
all these videos please give this one a
thumbs-up and it also love to hear what
you think about the videos and any
comments might have if you want to leave
one below this episode and stay tuned
for netflix